[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très content
d'être là j'espère que vous avez une
pause sympathique
si je suis ici ce soir c'est pour vous
parler de mon parcours mais un parcours
aussi qui a permis à d'autres jeunes à
des jeunes de pouvoir s'émanciper et
savoir dépasser les obstacles qu'ils
rencontrent sur leur chemin je viens
d'un quartier à roubaix à l'alma où j'ai
grandi qui m'a permis de grandir avec
des personnes venant de diverses
cultures
mais dans ce quartier
c'était il y avait un ancien une
atmosphère anxiogène
j'étais c'était plus rassurant et
j'étais souvent très haut pressés durant
mon enfance mon adolescence
j'avais l'impression que le problème qui
avait au fond de moi était dû à l'autre
à celui qui habite dans le bloc d'à côté
voir dans l'appartement d'à côté mais
d'autres jeunes qui pensaient
certainement comme moi qui pensais que
je pouvais être le problème du coût à
cet âge-là je me disais que pour pouvoir
m'émanciper pour pouvoir prendre place
dans le quartier il fallait que je
devienne plus fort donc je me suis
naturellement dirigés vers les sports de
combat en me disant qu'en étant plus
fort que l'autre en ayant la capacité de
pouvoir le battre de pouvoir le dépasser
mais je serai plus confiant je me
sentirais plus rassuré je retrouverai
une certaine liberté
j'ai été dans les sports de combat je me
suis entraîné et durant plusieurs années
g
j'ai compris que certes j'avais plus
confiance en moi beaucoup plus confiance
en moi mais je me sentais encore
prisonnier prisonnier de cet univers de
béton des bâtiments des maisons les rues
le quartier en lui-même ne me rassurait
pas et je voyais pas l'horizon et du
coup pour pour passer le temps avec avec
les copains avec les amis on se donnait
des défis tout le monde a joué au jeu de
la lave et un adolescent enfin enfants
en se disant interdiction de toucher le
sol tu dois aller de la halle à sans
toucher le sol
tout le monde l'a déjà fait donc c'est
ce qu'on faisait mais sauf qu'on était
des ados et on se donner des défis tu
arriveras à sauter au dessus de 7 et tu
arriverais aller jusque là bas sans
toucher le sol etc
est-ce que tu cours plus vite que moi et
un jour révélation je vais sur internet
et là je vois une vidéo de david belle
et des yamakasi
les mecs se déplacer à des vitesses
folles avec une aisance déconcertante et
avec une facilité surprenante et ces
personnes on les appelle des traceurs
c'est des pratiquants du parcours avec
un cas on peut les applaudir
moi mais diary et david romero merci les
gars
et en fait j'ai tout de suite compris
que il fallait que je fasse absolument
il fallait que je puisse me déplace
aussi dans dans ma ville de nous de
toute façon la plus aisé possible
et du coup on est tout de suite allé
s'entraîner sur la première barre qu'on
a trouvé une petite barrière et on
pouvait y rester des heures
un petit hic quand même c'est que
j'avais peur de glisser de tomber de me
faire mal et que cette peur je la voyais
comme un fardeau comme quelque chose de
très négatif
je me disais que il fallait pas qu'elle
existe si elle était là c'était une
tente de faiblesse est bien plus tard
j'ai compris une chose par rapport à ça
j'y reviendrai
et du coup on a continué à s'entraîner
avec les copains au début c'était juste
de l'amusement pour faire plaisir et au
fur et à mesure l'entraînement devenait
de plus en plus sérieux de plus en plus
intense et on a commencé à aller plus
loin a décidé on est sorti de notre
ville
on a découvert la métropole on la
connaissait du bout des doigts et on est
parti à paris dans l'est de la france en
angleterre en italie en afrique en asie
etc
et l'objectif c'est découvrir d'autres
texture nouvelle architecture de
nouvelles personnes rencontrer d'autres
traceur d'autres pratiquants de parcours
échanger sur la discipline est ce qu'on
s'est dit c'est que le parcours au delà
de dépasser l'obstacle physique ça
permettait aussi de dépasser les
obstacles mentaux c'est à dire que un
examen un rendez vous amoureux une une
problématique familiale un entretien
d'embauché
tous pouvaient être dépassés à partir du
moment où répéter où on analyser ce
qu'on avait à faire et qu'on décide et
de oz et qu'on décide et conduit au
moment où on décide de dépasser ses
peurs celle là
on comprend que on peut tout tout est
accessible
rien est impossible aucune muraille net
infranchissable et que juste avec la
force de la persévérance on pouvait y
arriver
mais au passage en rencontrant d'autres
pratiquants de parcours on a découvert
la philosophie et il ya une phrase qui a
été qui a résonné en moi qui étais être
fort pour être utile c'est vraiment la
base dans le parcours dans l'art du
déplacement et je me suis dit c'est
génial
au début je voulais être fort pour être
fort mais ça n'avait aucun sens mais
être fort pour être utile à mais c'est
super et sauf que quand on est jeune
adulte fin de l'essence du mont fort
pour être utile aux quais dans le
parcours qu'on mange ça peut être utile
le parcours savait déjà oublié vos clés
c'est déjà arrivé à tout le monde
j'imagine qu'est ce que vous faites vous
allez voir le un serrurier
ou alors vous allez attendre devant chez
vous un certain un certain temps à nous
en passer oui passé en passer par notre
fenêtre et on rentre chez nous c'était
utile et ensuite il y avait aussi utile
on se dit oui mais imaginons il ya cas
extrêmes une personne est en danger il
ya un feu ou quoi que ce soit ça serait
génial qu'on puisse utiliser nos
capacités physiques pour aller l'aider
bon ça on rencontre tête une fois dans
sa vie une situation comme ça où est-ce
qu'on peut utiliser nos capacités
physiques pour aller aider quelqu'un
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on peut
l'utiliser mais on voulait être fort
pour être utile mais utile dans la vie
de tous les jours et en pratiquant en
s'entraînant en faisant des vidéos qui
était de plus en plus impressionnantes
comme vous avez pu le voir il y avait
des on s'est retourné et on a vu plein
de jeunes pleins d'autres jeunes parfois
très jeune et on s'est dit si un jour il
y en a un qui tombe qui se fait mal
qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qui peut nous arriver qu'est
ce qui va leur arriver serait dramatique
et les parents aussi était très inquiet
d'accord parce que il voyait mal leurs
enfants apprendre de manière autodidacte
la pratique du parcours du coup on a
créé l'association parcours 59 qui a
pour but de promouvoir le parcours mais
aussi de pouvoir encadrer tous les
publics de 3 ans jusqu'à 77 ans et en
passant par un public handicapé etc
pourquoi parce que le parcours qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une méthode
d'entraînement qui permet d'aller d'un
point a à un point b le plus rapidement
et le plus efficacement possible
en franchissant les obstacles du milieu
urbain ou naturel
c'est une nouvelle manière de se
déplacer on a deux bras deux jambes mais
aujourd'hui on est dans une époque qui
est très sédentarisés je veux dire par
là que on retravaille en prenant le
train le bus le métro la voiture on a
des escalators qu'on a des escaliers on
a des échelles on a des ascenseurs ont
tout est fait il ya même des seuls plats
ou est-ce qu'on vous avez déjà vu un
walt disney on peut se déplacer
on fait tout pour éviter qu'on se
déplace et mais en fait peut-être qu'on
a perdu quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
arrivent encore à grimper un mur et
c'est vraiment ce à l'origine du
mouvement qui était intéressante et
aussi la philosophie profonde qu'il ya
derrière la discipline du parcours et du
coup on s'est dit mais le parcours ça
peut être un outil formidable
déjà il est il se pratique en ville et
il ya une connotation un peu artistique
il ya quelque chose d'artistique dans le
mouvement on s'est dit pourquoi pas
confronter deux mondes qui se regardent
en chiens de faïence
la culture et le sport et donc on a
commencé à faire des représentations des
shows des spectacles etc
on a mis en valeur des produits pour de
grandes marques
on a fait des inaugurations etc et on a
décidé de faire un projet on en a fait
des centaines avec l'association
parcours 59 mais un en particulier où
l'objectif c'était d'amener les jeunes à
réinvestir leur ville c'est à dire que
beaucoup de jeunes pensent que le
quartier leur appartient mais tout le
reste de la ville appartient à une
certaine élite appartient d'autres
personnes l'objectif c'était qui
refusent viennent avec leur ville donc
du coup avec prenait des groupes de
jeunes il allait aux archives municipaux
aux archives du monde du travail et
faisait des recherches sur tel monument
ou tel monument et apprenez ce qui est
ce qu'il était avant ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui quelques anecdotes et du
coup les jeunes faisait des visites
guidées auprès d'eux
des pad ou de personnes lambda ou
d'autres jeunes tout en faisant du
parcours sdiri faisait du parcours ils
s'arrêtaient il expliqué à un certain
endroit qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici la
dentelle monuments et il continue donc
du coup ça a mené une nouvelle nouvelle
dynamique et l'objectif c'était que les
jeunes puissent respecter leur ville
respecte et les monuments qui s'y
trouvent
se réapproprier le patrimoine est tout
seul dans une connotation éducatif on
s'est dit si on arrive à faire le lien
entre le sport et la culture
on peut faire aussi le sport et
l'insertion le projet par courtes et
monuments on a exposé à l'agencé pour
l'éducation par le sport
- tant que président de l'association je
l'exposé à l'assemblée nationale on a
été lauréat national en 2015
hellal agences de l'éducation par le
sport m'a invité à rejoindre leur équipe
en tant qu'ordinateur pour le programme
déclic sportif qui a pour but d'insérer
des sportifs vers le monde professionnel
en utilisant les valeurs que les jeunes
sportifs dans les clubs portent déjà
c'est à dire que tout patron
d'entreprise a besoin que son employé
soit ponctuelle soit engagée et l'esprit
de compétition du challenge qui dès
qu'ils aient envie qu'il a envie de voir
plus loin qu'il envie de se défier et
qu'il est une bonne interaction sociale
et ça dans les clubs il n'y en a des
masses c'est un vivier de jeunes
incroyable et surtout que les éducateurs
sportifs des clubs connaissent très bien
leur gêne parfois même mieux que lorsque
que la propre famille d'aider des jeunes
en question et s'était essayé de
l'objectif de ce programme déclic
sportif d'amener les jeunes vers le
monde professionnel en utilisant les
valeurs qu'ils portent au fond d'eux en
les mettant en exergue et en travaillant
avec eux pendant plusieurs semaines
en immersion complète sur celle là voilà
tout ça pour vous dire que le parcours
comme tous les autres sports sont des
outils formidables et que le sport ne
fait pas que des champions mais peut
faire aussi des personnes extrêmement
engagé passionné et qui peuvent trouver
de nouvelles idées
voilà je vous remercie
[Musique]
c'est vrai
ouais